pierre hier matin marlène schiappa était
l'invité de thomas sotto sur rtl
visiblement le journaliste il était un
petit peu obsédé par moi tomasso 2
puisqu'il n'a pas arrêté de la relance
et sur ses déclarations d'il ya quelques
jours il expliqué ouais expliqué me
verrais bien animé le débat d'entre deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle
et c'est vrai que thomas sotto il parler
de sujets sérieux et thomas stoy a voulu
faire le buzz absolument thomas sotto il
était plus sympa quand il peut demander
du travail à l'époque sur europe 1 et
qui voulait absolument avoir une tranche
c'est dingue hein c'est fou ce harper
qu'il est à la radio maintenant ils s'en
foutent vous prenez position pour dire
que vous verriez bien cyril hanouna
coprésenté le débat d'entre deux tours
de la prochaine fois en six mois mais
est ce que c'est vraiment le sujet du
moment est-ce que c'est pas ça votre
quête insatiable du buzz
vous savez parfaitement qu'en tenant ce
genre de propos ça va être repris qu'on
va vous interrogez là dessus et ça veut
pas dire qu'on s'intéresse pas d'autres
sujets bas excusez moi je l'aï vu marine
shom encore une fois vous choisissez vos
questions j'allais au présent je vous
explique qu' il ya un travail des
pompiers de paris qui est fondamental
contre le coaching vous choisissez de me
relancer sur cyril hanouna mais parce
que c'est la question que vous fait
diversion au fond pourquoi est ce que
c'est votre question on est dans une
émission d'actualité vous choisissiez de
m'interroger quatre fois sur cyril
hanouna
merci beaucoup à vous et c'est pas que
ça se passe au gouvernement ce qui vous
donne les réponses mais nous de
rédacteur en chef de ne pas les
questions pour les interviews ça se
passe plutôt très bien merci à même avec
ce soit alors alors thomas sotto oui
vous dire j'ai en plus j'ai toujours
défendues tomates ont été hyper sympa
avec lui et maintes et maintes fois il
m'a appelé pour que je range des petits
coups je dis la vérité
voilà à europe 1 albert d'ailleurs
exactement il me voyez c'est vrai que la
julie un truc thomas c'est lui qui veut
faire le buzz qui peut faire le pas ce
qui l'attend la petite phrase et au lieu
de s'intéresser aux vrais sujets et
après il va dire que je veux il veut
s'intéresser aux réfugiés et que ces
démissions d'actualité mais il pense
qu'à une chose voilà on me l'a dit j'ai
eu des échos d'rtl
il paraît qu'il va parler de moi avant
avant de rentrer c'est à part les deux
mois après donc il veut une petite
phrase elle veut surfer sur le buzz
thomas sotto et thomas sotto il c'est
vrai que je le dis il en difficulté avec
son émission sur france 2 politique qui
marche pas du tout voilà donc il essaie
de créer le buzz
moi j'ai toujours été super cool avec
lui et c'est vrai que voilà je suis un
petit peu déçu par son comportement a
thomas sotto et c'est vrai que quand il
m'appellera pour me demander quelque
chose maintenant
hihi bailly marie puis de recevoir paris
j'ai trouvé même justin en bois monty
ouais j'ai trouvé très insultant il
était tout le temps il revenait là
dessus j'ai bien écouté nos morts
qu'elle venait parler des pompiers
travaillent des ponts qui laisse un mari
quand le calacs au vide c'est quand même
plus important que de revenir aux mises
en cause et vous ne s'y oppose et oui
voilà il y avait un petit côté caca
nerveux jalousie je vais vous montrer ce
que ce dont je suis capable et mal pour
le coup je suis pas toujours d'accord
avec marlène schiappa mais je trouve
qu'elle a été par cette voie là je suis
100% tinmar lynnsha pages qu'elle était
extrêmement droite est extrêmement
pertinentes et malgré tout il est
responsable de ces questions
bah oui je vraiment il cherche ça non
mais bien au fait pourquoi il s'acharne
sur elle comme ça il lui reproche de
vouloir faire du buzz mais c'est lui qui
fait du buzz et maintient pas pardon a
là rien demandé est là il veut on va
surfer sur le buzz
il arrivera conduisent à une question
d'un journaliste expliqué marlène
schiappa c'est que il faisait un
portrait sur moi dans l'oubli l'on
appelait diverses personnes dont marlène
schiappa parce qu'il était sûrement venu
en algérie alors on lui pose une
question sur ont elle va pas parler
d'autre chose donc forcément plus elle
n'explique à 8,06 à plusieurs mois parce
que c'est il ya très longtemps il valait
et puis il démarre en disant est ce que
c'est bien le sujet du moment où il pose
quatre occasions ce qui n'est pas le
sujet du moment si ça donc c'est en plus
et pas de jugement elle a fait
l'interview il ya trois mois pour
appâter qui seront l'oubli c'est comme
ça que ça s'est passé exactement
oui il reprend je vous la faire du buzz
tout en lui faisant je suis un petit peu
déçu parce que ça saute aussi plus c'est
un mec de buzz mais voilà qui veut
absolument buzz et voilà il veut il veut
il rattrapé par tout moyen par l'erc son
émission franchement personne n'en parle
pas bien sûr donc apprendre à nous
lâcher ben wallace et c'est vrai qu'il a
réussi un chiffre en rade au son des
trompes otages étaient souvent bah oui
mais je n'ai pas du tout trouvé
insultant sérieux je trouve que pendant
que powell c'est normal elle veut parler
de sujets concernant ok elle le fait
elle veut parler des pompiers mais vous
vous doutez bien un instant il la reçoit
il va lui parler de ça je ne peux pas
dire à la barre il est revenu je dormais
laissez parler tu changes elle adore
malène marlène schiappa mais je trouve
qu'à s'est offusqué un petit peu trop
facilement connais le site et médiatique
il a raison de le souligner elle sait
que ça va faire partie des questions
mais maintenant il a été non sincèrement
il a été archi louvre moi j'écoutais il
a été archi lourd vraiment et à chaque
fois elle le renvoyer dans l'est dans
les cordes il a été très longuement plus
ce qui dérange en fait cyril si c'est ça
c'est cette idée si vous vous toucher au
pré carré d'une certaine élite de
journalistes et cantons prennent aux
médias le blog journalistes qui le
prennent très bien y en a qu à bien les
plus intelligents le prennent bien mais
d'autres se prennent très belle en
disant c'est nina qui va co présenter le
débat journalistes qui sont sûrs de leur
force et version et et sûrs d'eux ils le
prennent bien parce qu'ils disent au
contraire ça peut être marrant on
regarde et christophe barbier qui
excellent jean michel aphatie qui la
touche avaient bien pris qu'excellents
aussi voilà jean pierre elkabbach sonia
mabrouk laurence ferrari pascal praud je
sais que marco fu jen il a rien contre
ça non plus voilà qui sont des mecs qui
sont à un niveau voilà où ça se voit là
ça leur passe au dessus s'en fichent
totalement mais ce qu'essaie de faire du
buzz et ceux qui ont des difficultés
comme thomas sotto force ça le dérange
oui exactement c'est l'un de ceux qui
est remis en question par ça parce que
lui c'est vraiment la vieille politique
le vieux journalisme traditionnel d'eau
qui se dit surtout pas ça et ils tentent
de lui faire dire et elle le met
complètement ko
tiffany marlène schiappa quand elle lui
dit mes concerts votre ligne éditoriale
parce que la ligne éditoriale c'est
quand même les gens qui écoutent et lui
le pensait qu'à lui donc à lui a mis une
grosse carpe pêche nicolas non moi j'ai
trouvées insiste en méprisant alors j'ai
jamais trop aimé mais il est ému une
fois sur le plateau et vous aviez été
effectivement très gentil avec jour
trois personnes vendu que j'ai déjà mon
chéri mais thomas sotto j'ai pas j'ai
jamais trouvé qu'il avait un charisme
énorme mais là en l'occurrence j'ai
trouvé c'est un grave dérapage
parce qu'il était extrêmement insistant
et il a voulu la mettre en difficulté
alors que savait pas durer je veux le
dire la vérité j'étais un petit peu déçu
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui m'apaise
maintes et maintes fois et valérie elle
s'il était avec nous quand on était à
l'époque et c'est vrai que j'y vois là
j'essaie de me ranger les coûts parce
que je l'aimé bien et je suis un petit
peu déçu voilà que son comportement
voilà je vous dis moi j'aime bien les
gens qui restent sur une lignée et que
voilà qui qui voilà qui crache pas dans
la soupe maison sert il ya ce côté quand
même blessé c'est ce que disait je sais
plus qui l'assurent l'intelligentia qui
pensent que vous n'avez rien à faire
dans ce débat politique
et ça c'est vraiment la grosse connerie
on a besoin demain d'avoir des jeunes
qui votent et ils vont être très très
important surtout avec la souffrance
qu'ils ont et qu'ils vivent en ce moment
donc il faut absolument qu'il ya un
mineur qui leur parle et qu'il comprenne
enfin discours politique mais je pense
que vous êtes le seul un merci c'est la
connerie colas et labrecque sonnerie de
thomas sotto
je ne suis pas d'accord mou sur le côté
méprisant parce que je sais moi pour en
avoir discuté avec lui que soto
profondément aime beaucoup de syrie
écoutez moi je vous dis moi qui même en
coulisses et qui me dérange dans la
reddition
ça suffit ça c'est facile à danville
souplesse ça suffit et je vais vous dire
je le dis aux téléspectateurs combien je
reçois de sms qui me dépens des mets tu
sais cyril moi je t'adore je te des
formidables et quand ils sont à
l'antenne
ils ont honte de le dire où il doit
défendre donc thomas sotto si même bien
et ben écoute qui malheureusement c'est
parce qu'ils y voient là c'est tout ce
prospectus est le bastion l'obsédait en
tant que joueur depuis quatre jours il
le ferait s'il sera pas compte que le
temps est passé et continue à jésus par
la jalousie touba soleil chaque fois
qu'il ya quelque chose à me demander
il n'hésite pas